hi and welcome to the panel on
maximizing benefits and minimizing harms
with language technologies
i am hal dummy i'm a senior principal
researcher at microsoft research in new
york city um and although she's not here
uh with us today uh this this panel and
the topic was co-designed with alexander
olteano who's
at microsoft research in montreal
um so just to give a little bit of
context and goals around what we uh
hope to cover uh in this panel so
the the observation that we're starting
from is that language plays a
significant role in how people
understand and construct the social
world
and so this means that technologies that
involve human language which we'll
briefly uh refer to as human language
technologies or hlt which is supposed to
be inclusive of text and speech and
dialogue and sign language and anything
that um
is language related
can contribute both positively and
negatively to to people in the social
world um
through uh through interactions
so we're going to talk about this from
two sides so one is the the sort of
maximizing benefit side so you know how
can human language technologies
challenge power support and serve
individuals and communities
and also from the perspective of
minimizing harm so who's being excluded
by current language technologies who
benefits and who loses
uh so we have a panel of um four
esteemed researchers who have i think uh
both
a depth and breadth of knowledge across
these areas that um that i
uh that i really believe will lead to
interesting discussion um so i'm going
to let each of them introduce themselves
um briefly and we're just going to go
alphabetically and and first is steven
byrd
thanks hal hi from lara care country i'm
professor at charles darwin university
i've been living and working in a remote
aboriginal community in the far north of
australia over the last five years
where i'm learning to speak the local
language kunwengu which has about 2 000
speakers and i'm working on new methods
for transcription language learning and
intergenerational transmission of
culture
wonderful um next is su lynn
hi um my name is dylan blodgett i'm a
postdoc researcher at microsoft research
in montreal i'm working very broadly on
social and ethical implications of
language technologies
and margaret
uh yeah hi i'm margaret mitchell
i'm a researcher in a lot of sort of
different domains and companies um
although most recently i'm joining
hugging face as some sort of chief ai
ethic something but we're still working
on the title
uh it's a startup so get to choose
titles
um and yeah my background is largely in
natural language processing some
computer vision thrown in assistive
technology thrown in a bit and then
ethics and ai type stuff
uh and last we have hannah wallach hey
everyone um as hal said i'm hannah
wallock i'm a partner research manager
at microsoft research new york
and my background is in machine learning
and specifically machine learning for
text
sometimes social networks these kinds of
things
but for the past six years or so i've
been focusing mainly on issues of
fairness and transparency as they relate
to ai and machine learning
and over the past year or two in
particular i sort of returned to my
roots in
models for text and stuff like that and
i've been thinking a lot about fairness
related issues in the context of
language technologies
great um yeah so thank you everyone for
being here um we're spanning wide time
zones and so i appreciate both early
morning people and and evening people
for for making the time
um so we're going to start with uh
discussion around um sort of like
benefits and how um human language
technologies can um conserve communities
so the first the question i want to
start out with
um is what are some examples of projects
you've worked on or know of
where human language technologies are
used in the service of users or
communities to make their lives better
and maybe we can start with stephen
thanks hal so in a lot of indigenous
communities um people have managed to
make extended recordings
of stories and
information about families and places
and the initial focus of a lot of
technology work in this space is to make
our transcription easier
to accelerate that process
but that really puts things into the
written mode which local people don't
command
and so another
language technology that may be more
applicable is spoken document retrieval
where people could access the content of
large audio
archives
in the oral modality exclusively
yeah does anyone want to jump in on this
um i sort of want to speak to the
framing of the question which somewhat
hilariously referred to people as users
um so the question was around the
service
technologies in the service of users um
and i think you know part of the framing
of sort of ethical ai work and
understanding both benefits and harms is
to understand that there are users
consumers and they're also those
affected um and we tend to say users
when we mean people
and so just kind of like understanding
the question itself and the framing
there is sort of i think indicative of
the sort of mindsets we have in
technology um but you know once we can
sort of
understand humans uh as people
uh i think then there's you know a lot
of stuff that can be done that is useful
so i haven't done anything uh like
steven or dr byrd
has done but i have worked on things
like
trying to predict mild cognitive
impairment using the kind of language
that people produce for narrative
retellings um
trying to
describe images for people who are blind
or name objects things like that
um and so
in the assistive and augmentative space
um there's a lot of good that can be
done um as well as in sort of more like
corporate contexts but i think like the
assistive and augmentative
aspect of machine learning and nlp is is
one of the most beneficial
and maybe i can just jump in there and
talk a very little bit about a project
that i worked on
gosh in the mid 2000s at this point so
2004 to 2007 or so
um
this was back when i was a phd student
at university of cambridge working with
david mackay
who had created a program called dasha
and the whole idea behind dasha was that
it was a user interface that would help
people input text and so it was intended
not so much for those of us who are
perfectly capable of sitting around and
typing on a keyboard but for people who
needed other ways of interacting with a
computer or a system and what was so
exciting about dasher was that it wasn't
just a user interface you know let's say
a bunch of like um you know words or
letters that somebody would have to
somehow navigate to and select either
with a you know i don't know a mouse or
a head mouse or any other kind of device
like that but it's it had a language
model that sort of powered the entire
thing and this language model would
adjust what was visible on the screen
based on what the person had previously
input and it's a little bit hard to
describe if you haven't heard of it i do
recommend sort of checking it out
there's certainly screenshots and
probably videos and stuff around but the
language model would basically uh
control sort of the user interface so
that areas of the screen that were more
probable
um so letters that were words that were
more probable would be placed in bigger
areas of the screen and in this way you
could kind of zoom towards these bigger
areas of the screen that were more
likely to be the things that you wanted
to say
and it was a much more efficient way of
inputting text then sort of pecking out
individual letters on a on a keyboard
yeah that system is awesome
i think i remember that it would do eye
tracking so like if you looked at one
corner it would start getting bigger
that's right that's right exactly so
yeah so that was there are a number of
different devices that that david and
others tried connecting it to
to actually um control the system
one was a head mouse there was also a
breath mouse so you could breathe and
kind of control the system um eye
tracking was certainly something that
that folks experimented with yeah a
whole bunch of different things and of
course you could just use a a regular
mouse like we're all used to as well
or even a stylus i i did a little bit of
work trying to put the dasher system on
the
the compact ipac which was a handheld
computing device that nobody remembers
at this point but we thought it might be
fun to um to have it on there as a way
of as a way of inputting text rather
than using an on-screen keyboard
i think there's like an interesting
thread that connects all three of these
which is sort of um
[Music]
tailoring the the language system to
cases where
um the users either like prefer or don't
really have access for for one reason or
another to like certain modalities and
thinking about like how to use access
and other modalities to like bridge that
gap
yeah i think that's right although i
guess i want to emphasize that although
we're sort of highlighting these kinds
of things
language technologies are used all over
the place in in some you know extremely
mundane ways so when i think about for
example um
you know recently of course we've all
been working from home and taking
meetings on things like teams and zoom
and many of these pieces of software
have built-in transcription services
that of course have a language model as
the back end
and actually maybe even there it is
about sort of accessing things in
different modalities i guess the meeting
itself is all you know often um
uh uh communicated with people speaking
and then you're sort of trying to turn
this into
into into text so actually maybe maybe
even there it sort of fits your your
pattern how
maybe this is the future
i mean there are uses that are not just
augmentative and assistive um and so
i feel like less inclined to focus on
those because i think sort of the tech
sector generally is is very good at
selling
ideas uh that are just sort of like
generally good for people or they call
them users and so i just feel like less
inclined to
lean into that but i mean you know as
someone who's worked in nlp
you know you can use uh technology to do
information extraction where if you want
to learn about for example like some
longitudinal behavior around some sort
of organization
uh then you can extract these and pull
out provenance of
uh different strings and you can get
sentiment and you know toxicity and
stance and opinion
you know all these different things
where if you're trying to learn or
flesh out information in some way
there's a thing called knowledge based
population
obviously these tools are very very
helpful
it's very easy to
do basic analysis on the bible i've
learned that
if you bring in some basic language
technology i like blew away one of my
religion phd friends that i could like
pull out you know all examples of the
right hand of god and everything that
was going on and stuff like that and so
it can be really useful in any sort of
large research domain
um and i think that's sort of a large
reason why people work on nlp is this
kind of stuff i mean that was a big
focus of my research before i moved into
the area of fairness and transparency
and stuff i i did a lot of work on topic
models as a tool for social scientists
to use to understand large document
collections um
yeah absolutely my fav my favorite
example there you know drawing on your
comment about the bible was analyzing a
data set of ufo sightings you get some
very interesting some very interesting
topics that that emerge there
there's another aspect of the framing of
the question
about users and that is i think the
assumption that technology is for
individuals
so in places where
the only device people have is mobile
phones
and the local practice of ownership is
that things are shared
means that you can't assume that a
device is for one
individual
and so maybe they'll be
used by multiple people for instance to
look at or to consume media
that be a popular use of a mobile device
but to have a dyadic one-on-one
connection between a person and the
machine is is not really that
common or not continuous
how do you find that that
dynamic affects how you think about
like the technologies and the the
systems that you want to develop
i've been thinking about a triangular
relationship with two people using
a technology for example a linguist
sitting with a speaker using
transcription software
or
a linguist sitting with a monolingual
older speaker and having a younger
person
interpret
most of the engagements seem to involve
three
points
and i'm looking at ways to substitute
one of them
with technology
or to assist one of them with technology
rather than technology over being a
surrogate for a person
yeah so i wanted to sort of circle back
to um actually margaret's previous point
um which was going to be a
i was going to use as a transition to
the next question but there was this
good side uh sidebar in the middle um so
the the example you gave about you know
using language technology to investigate
um document collections or um you know
histories of
an organization or something it reminded
me of
um this ruling that came down in france
a couple of years ago now that
apparently you're not allowed to use
statistical analysis on judges decisions
now that's not talking about nlp that's
just looking at machine learning um yeah
yeah sort of like machine learning
statistical systems but obviously like
the court system and everything else
produces also lots and lots of text and
so
um
i think this naturally sort of leads to
this question of you know how can
language technologies be used to
challenge power structures like the
courts or like other things
um or to support minorized or
disenfranchised
people or communities
i can start maybe but uh
it like it will be maybe a little bit of
a cantankerous sort of answer um i think
um
like one
i think you're your example uh
margaret actually like
um is very related to some work that one
of my lab mates did katie keith on kind
of like automatically identifying the
names of people killed by police from
newspapers and the goal of this project
was to kind of aid like the work um of
people you know humans right who do this
manually and it's an exhausting kind of
labor
um but the compilation these kind of
databases right of the names of people
killed by police is like a thing that is
important to have because there are not
existing records by you know people in
power so this was kind of seen as like
one way maybe to hold power to account
right but i also
think a lot of the ways we could imagine
using language technologies in this way
like to travel through large numbers of
documents to find evidence of kind of
like certain kind of patterns or
whatever like
um can be really valuable they also kind
of uh can sort of be powered by these
logics of like quantification right like
you require this kind of like evidence
in order to hold power to account right
it's not as though you need to add more
names to your database to know about
police abuses right it's not that like
you know we have plenty of evidence
about that already
um
so i think like for a lot of these kinds
of cases also kind of a lot of nlp for
social good sort of you know oh um let's
kind of narrow the digital divide let's
you know provide i said let's better
education this kind of thing like we
have like data language technologies
they're sort of like logics of
quantification or logics of scale
that i kind of find
risky
um hal i think margaret you wanted to
say something so go ahead well
um yeah so uh yeah so first like sulin
makes great points as always um i did i
was pondering your original framing of
the question how and the relationship to
judicial decisions and things like that
and so i do sort of want to flag
something that everyone here knows but
you know whoever is watching it may not
know that there's a lot of work on
fairness and bias and the justice system
and a lot of things that have shown that
uh really problematic human biases with
racism and sexism are reflected in the
data that we learn from and so you know
the french ruling makes a lot of sense
given that it's most likely that uh the
kinds of predictions that would be made
would not challenge existing power
structures but actually reinforce them
um and so um
so i was
i was having difficulty tying your
question to i think a little bit of the
segway of what it was about because i
would say that example is not an example
of a benefit
because it goes into harm oh i agree
yeah yeah
um
yeah so so that's yeah so that's a
that's a trickier one but um
yeah i don't know that there's much more
that i was going to say there other than
maybe to say that like when you're
thinking of
supporting
um
marginalized or disenfranchised
individuals there's a lot of utility in
working with language generation
technologies and so like
for me a prime example is that i
developed so much anxiety over writing
emails because my emails were used to
judge my personality and character and
there's this you know there's this whole
understanding of how women are supposed
to talk and email like if you just say
yeah
you're me you have to say yeah
exclamation point or yeah happy face
like all this kind of stuff and so uh
when auto suggest
was coming out and uh auto compose smart
compose and all these things there were
a lot of people like the bias and
fairness world like this is a horrible
idea and i was like what are you talking
about this is a great idea now i don't
have to like guess how to sound like a
person like people want me to sound i
could just have smart compose write it
for me and uh oftentimes it comes up
with good ideas and so i think like
there is a lot of uh useful things for
supporting sort of disenfranchised
populations
especially in natural language
generation
i wanted to jump in here too and just
point out a situation where language
technologies may perpetuate existing
power structures
[Music]
because it may involve a minority of
people constructing technological
solutions for everyone
and it's built on this idea that we can
make people's lives better
often without involving them in the
design process
and that deprives people of their agency
and in a colonized space
one of the causes of language
endangerment is that
denial of local agency and
self-determination
so the very idea of solving social
problems with technology
is is kind of flawed actually
yeah that was going to go to
um sort of a a side question i had which
is you know i think
i don't know about in the nlp or human
language technology space but um you
know more broadly i think
there are plenty of examples of
technology that sort of
developed with one thing in mind but
then gets reappropriated
and
i mean steven brought up you know
involving
the communities that uh will presumably
use or be impacted by technology in
the design and development um or
possibly just not designing or
developing at all
which might be the better answer in some
cases but um yeah what are people's
thoughts around
you know like
how can we try to
um develop things that that are actually
useful and help empower people
i mean this is certainly something that
that we've been thinking about a bunch
um
lately within microsoft and and i guess
i actually want to kick this over to sue
lynn who in particular i think has been
doing some really interesting thinking
about these
these kinds of things and participatory
approaches and stuff like that
yeah i uh i actually was going to say
something slightly different but i can
also talk about i can also talk about
that i think
um i think certainly uh so i think
certainly participatory approaches are
appealing i think they're not a panacea
i think like you know we
especially as they've been adopted not
in nlp but in a machine learning they've
been kind of adopted as a way to kind of
like
avert fairness related harms
rather than to like dismantle like you
know the relationships of power that are
that um that kind of undergirds the
entire process of technological
development um and usually they don't
come with like uh you know with like
maybe we shouldn't build this in the
first place right so um and people have
written about this very monastery this
is a great paper story
you know it's not a design fixed machine
for machine learning or something like
this
um
i had another thought originally but
it's escaped me how can you restate the
question
um
so the question was about
reappropriation of technology um how
things that can be perhaps designed with
sort of doing good in mind can get
you know taken by whoever has power and
uh and used
to maintain the power rather than
flip it
it doesn't look like that's healthy no
no i haven't recovered the thought i
mean i'm sure it was a great one but
indigenous communities are really
masters of
reappropriation and fix things and make
things with whatever is to hand and
that's an example of people's resilience
in the face of many threats to their
agency
i feel that the
hci community
and people working on ubiquitous
computing are leading the way and we in
the language technology community could
take a look at what they're doing and
also maybe seek ways of collaborating
with them because they've had
a 50-year history of participatory
design and co-design of
democratizing the design process
and we in nlp
um
are following in their footsteps maybe
not realizing it
i did recover my thought um
and i think it was in response to um a
different part of your question which is
like how do you how do we design things
to actually make them useful
um
and the thought actually comes from the
fact that i think like this is just uh
i've been doing a lot of thinking i'm
interested in other people's thoughts
too on kind of like the sh how kind of
nlp tasks are within nlps like a
research field right are
defined what the boundaries of these
tasks are and how many of them in
pursuit of something like natural
language understanding actually back
really poorly onto things that people
would actually want solved or would want
as solutions for things right um and it
kind of all has all come up because
we've been we've been doing some
thinking um uh on on participatory
design and what that might look like for
nlp but there's some settings where this
might be just incoherent right with this
pd for something like and a lot of
natural language inference like which is
a very kind of it's like a classical nlp
task right for
like natural language understanding but
like it it and maybe aspects of the
technologies right the architectures or
the data sets developed to solve this
eventually get used
in kind of um applications out in the
world but it's not clear how kind of
this task framing right supports
developing technologies let's help
people
um and so i have been doing a lot of
thinking about kind of like the
boundaries of mlp tasks and how they
actually map on to
um problems that people might actually
want solved
um and whether or not it is incoherent
to try to apply kind of like approaches
or or like pd to kind of how we
understand and bound nlp tasks
and i think a lot of
sorry
i was just going to note that i think a
lot of nlp tasks
were chosen because they were feasible
several years ago or decades ago and not
even necessarily super influenced by
what people might want or by or might
need but more by sort of hey we can do
this with the currently available
technology
this reminds me a little bit of there
was this paper by amerishi at all in kai
2019 where they introduced this term ai
infused systems to sort of try to get
away from this like notion of autonomous
systems or
you know something that's going to like
solve the whole task and like really try
to put the
um
uh
the notion of like
trying to use in this case ai
technologies but like human language
technologies for us um
in ways that are like directly exposed
to the end user in ways that like
actually help that user rather than
you know sort of like completely solve
some tasks that we defined
you know and many years ago
um but i think this boundaries thing
that suelin brings up is really
interesting because i think there's like
there's task boundaries and there's also
sort of field boundaries so
um when we were talking about projects
like um like dasher and spoken document
retrieval and you know object detection
for blind or low vision users
these are not topics that
appear super commonly in the main
sort of nlp or perhaps even speech
and certainly like machine learning
fields
and yet in some ways they seem to be the
ones that
are
like useful like plausibly to people and
um you know and why why is that like uh
is this a historical accident or is
something else going on here
it also yeah it's also occurred to me
i'd love to hear people's thoughts on
this but it's also occurred to me that
um search like in you know lives in a
different kind of like academic
place than nlp which is kind of i mean
it's always struck me as absurd given is
that if you ask people what language
technologies they encounter on a regular
basis search is probably like one of the
first three things that they would say
um so i also have kind of like maybe a
cantankerous or like cranky answer so i
was sort of
pausing to see maybe i don't want to say
anything but i mean my sense is that a
lot of people don't care
i mean it's it's useful to if you're
really really interested in optimization
for example
it's useful to be able to say in a paper
that this has some utility for some
application um but i think working on
applications which i think sort of is a
little bit what you're getting at how as
well is generally seen
as kind of less than working on things
that are more theoretical
um or on things that are just sort of
like bounded by some specific um you
know task framing like zulin brings up
um and so
you know it's i think sort of a
superficial interest that people will
mention in passing um because they're
actually interested in working on making
the number get higher whatever the
competition is right
uh or making the thing go faster or
whatever um and so
like you are i think exactly right that
although when you talk about like ai for
social good and things like that
um a lot of these sort of assistive
things come up as ideas because these
are applied
um uses of this technology but when you
look at the conferences and stuff and
what's uh
being published a lot of it is around
like novelty and so if you're
publishing or if you're trying to do a
system that brings together a lot of
pieces for some applied context like
that's not going to get accepted because
that's
less than sort of um so i think there's
just sort of a lack of care and
appreciation of what it takes
to actually have these sort of like for
good sort of uses
um where there really is a focus on
increasing things increasing the speed
increasing the size increasing the
number um and that's actually what what
people mostly care about unfortunately
and i think as well building these kinds
of systems that we've been talking about
often involves interdisciplinary work
and work that's challenging and requires
people to come together outside of a
single discipline and that kind of work
can be incredibly slow because you have
to figure out how
to work in that kind of context it's
also a style of work that ends up really
touching upon the messy realities of the
world
you sort of touched on this on this meg
but um you know it's much less
abstract and sort of theoretical and
neatly kind of contained and bounded and
manageable it's it's messy it's
uncomfortable it's difficult stuff takes
a really long time and i think that
means therefore that people are less
inclined to pursue that style of work
particularly against the backdrop of
increasingly people caring just about
numbers of publications and stuff like
that and you know citation counts and
all of these kinds of things i've long
said that that interdisciplinary work is
not a good way to boost one's citation
count or number of papers if anything
it's a great way to sort of slow these
things down because it's so hard to do
and and to get right and it just takes a
long time
i think there's this uh tokenistic way
that people refer to the social benefits
of their research as part of the
narrative
that's developed but not incorporated
into the evaluation and since
our field is proud about our evaluation
rigor
i feel like these ambit claims that are
made about the social good of the
technology ought to be subject to some
sort of evaluation as well
yeah and just to
um
uh add to that um i also think because
we really value maybe in the pursuit of
nlu or something right like work
nominally in the pursuit of nlu um work
that is abstracted away from deployment
settings it means that we
actually
we can we end up knowing so little about
the harms that these things actually
give rise to right we know that they're
probably going to you can look at what
the task is or what the system is and
say almost without you know with some
certainty something will happen that is
not great when you deploy this in a real
setting but because they never get
deployed by real setting in real
settings by academics right we don't um
we don't know and so we're left to kind
of speculate and say like probably this
is going to be terrible for someone or
lots of someone
but we just don't know and i kind of
find it i've been finding it like
shocking and kind of disappointing that
a lot of um the cases of these systems
gone wrong i
find out from
journalistic endeavors right and not
from not because we're writing about it
and publishing about it and talking
about in our communities because some
journalist is like hey did you know this
machine translation system is being used
in an immigration court and you're like
oh my god
no
so
so i think uh we've we've slightly you
know slowly segued over to harms anyway
so let's let's officially segue over to
harms
um so we've talked about this actually a
little bit already but i wanted to talk
about sort of inclusion
um
so
uh
you know
the technologies that we're talking
about generally speaking are being built
by a pretty narrow segment of the world
population um but but often sort of
expected or i don't know imagined to to
serve a much broader
um
population and so
um you know it may be like specific
examples could be useful here for cases
where you know you you can think of um
certain people or certain communities
being excluded
by current current um language
technology practices and then we've
talked about participatory design and
related things but you know are there
other forms of inclusion that that are
meaningful and not not sort of like
ethics washing
i think um there's a lot of very obvious
ways in which our practices um exclude
lots of people
across the pipeline and i think a lot of
other people can talk um can speak to
that uh so maybe i'll
not
um
i'll not i'll not talk about that to
start with um i think i wanna i was
thinking kind of pinging backing off
what we were just talking about right
the kind of work that we routinely
exclude from
um nlp kind of research
um so uh i think we exclude a lot of
slow work so emily bender's talked a lot
about this and other people um so i
think nlp research and practice even
when they are interested in measuring
harm or other social impacts really only
tend to inspect system behavior abstract
away from deployment settings we've um
and i think if we want to uncover the
impacts of these technologies or how
their how these technologies are
actually produced we need methods beyond
what we are employing right um often
interdisciplinary kinds of approaches
from different disciplines like hannah's
been talking about so like qualitative
methods or
interviews or participatory approaches
um and what we're doing right now is
like we kind of poke a system behavior
and say that you have that you know how
your system is biased or something like
this right can't possibly uncover
people's really subjective or lived
experiences with the technology or or
the the beliefs and practices and
organizational dynamics that actually
create these technologies so all this
stuff takes time
and they're methods that aren't used in
nlp
and produces you know probably less
flashy or or generalizable work or
something like this because it's context
dependent so we don't reward it um
so
um
i kind of uh
i
worry a lot um about this kind of work
and uh i think it's a shame that we're
not taking advantage of kind of the the
kind of many methods and um approaches
that are available to us to really kind
of uncover
what language technologies are like what
they look like in the world how they're
produced
most of the
world's languages are oral and
these are oral cultures people command a
repertoire of languages and switch
between them for different functions
where they are
and so language technologies which
presume text
and then which presume
normalize standardized text
have this
unfortunate consequence of reinforcing
the frame that you know
high prestige cultures are the ones with
written records
when you tell people who are writing oh
there's an orthography standard now and
you should write in the standard way the
unintended consequence is that people
write less because they know there's a
right way and they know they don't know
it
so um
one remedy i think is for
a
to to continue this acceleration of
interest in spoken language technologies
and to focus not on language
technologies for all so much as
looking at the regional varieties of
major world languages
which are spoken by every
remote person who is you know
multilingual but they still need to work
in the wider world and when they phone
that banking system or hotel booking
system if they've got charge in their
phone and so on they're not going to
speak in their local indigenous language
they'll speak in their regional variety
and this is
really not well supported by speech
technologies yet and that would be such
an empowering thing to do
yeah
um
i think you know inclusion is
you know not just limited to who's using
the technology and who's affected by the
technology but also
obviously the people at the table from
the start who are defining what the
technology is and i think
uh i think probably sue lynn first was
sort of hitting on that um
but you know i wanted to focus on this
point because i see uh inclusion
within tech creation circles as being
one of the most fundamental problems in
ai right now
um the fact that you can have some sort
of diversity by hiring people who you
see as below you but then you can't
retain them because they're alienated
right so you end up with the same you
know sub-population working on um
work for you know
all over the world and so um i just
really wanted to highlight that one of
the big barriers to moving forward
responsible ai down well-informed paths
is because largely inclusion is not
really done people don't understand what
inclusion is
um it means that you know if
if if you feel threatened that doesn't
mean you're being threatened if you feel
attacked that doesn't mean you're being
attacked right and so like communication
styles for different people at the table
are going to be very different depending
on their cultures and you know how
they've been raised and things like that
and if you are basically
implicitly or explicitly like putting
forward a norm of behavior and
communication style then you're going to
alienate most
most of the people who could come and
diversify um the kinds of problems that
are being looked at and um i think that
this is like
one of the things that is hard for
people in machine learning to or nlp to
really dig into because it's not seen as
a technical problem but it still is
fundamental to what kind of work gets
done minimally because if you have a
good idea and you're from a marginalized
population you tend to have to kind of
fight for it as opposed to just being
able to say it and fighting is
exhausting and also it makes people like
you less right so um you know if you
can't share an idea without having to
couch it in a very certain way that
conforms to some norms that other people
wrote
then you're not going to be able to you
know make cool decisions with other
people and that means the technology is
going to be reflecting a very myopic
view of what should be done and how the
world works
yeah um
i want to be mindful of time so we've
got about five minutes left
so i want to
switch on to the last question which is
i want to give everyone
you know one minute
to tell everyone who's watching
um
you know what would your one piece of
advice be that you could give to someone
working in the area of human language
technology is about how to do better
research or how to build better tools or
systems
what would that piece of advice be
and maybe we'll go reverse alphabetical
um so we'll start with hannah
yeah okay this is tough because i have
so many pieces of advice that i want to
give and and very limited time here
but
i think the biggest one for me comes
down to this
it you're not going to develop systems
that are responsible that treat people
fairly that behave in all of these ways
that we want if you
build your system without thinking about
all of these things and then turn around
sometime before or maybe even after
deployment and say
what can we do now how can we now try
and somehow make this system fair and so
for me it really comes down to changing
our development practices to prioritize
things like fairness things like
inclusion from day number one i i really
strongly plus one meg's point about if
you don't have an inclusive culture on
the development team you're not going to
build products that are inclusive and so
my number one piece of advice really is
start thinking about these things from
that very first second don't wait until
you're about to ship it
great and margaret um
yeah um so
i think one piece of advice that might
be quick uh is is the sort of quality
over quantity thing uh so people try and
publish a lot and look at number of
papers but if you can sort of have the
courage to nurture
your work then that might be less papers
but the papers will be more impactful or
you know go on a road show and show
people the cool thing you're doing
instead of just focusing on publishing
more papers like really dig into what
you're doing and nurture that further
is a really great way of standing out uh
in in the research world and having
people know what you're up to
sue lynn
yeah i think i'd say um
uh if you're building a system or you're
thinking about building a system um
think about all the assumptions that
you've made kind of like at every point
in the pipeline like it you know
whatever you're doing uh you have
implicitly explicitly made decisions
right about what the j what the problem
is and so you know should you build the
thing and who is it for and who does it
serve and
whose language is relevant or which
stakeholders are relevant for you to
consider and whose perspectives are you
foregrounding when you annotate and what
kinds of system behavior rewarding via
evaluation and all these kinds of things
right you've made all these decisions
and so um i would say always be thinking
about what kinds of assumptions about
language about speakers about
stakeholders
um
you are being kind of operationalized or
kind of leaned on when you're making
these decisions
and stephen
just to embrace oral culture that
surrounds us and to de-center our design
practices
this has been great
thank you all so much for uh taking this
time to share your expertise um with
with me and with everyone else um and i
said this at the beginning but i want to
thank again alexander eltiano who's at
microsoft research in montreal for
helping
come up with the idea of this panel and
and workshop questions and stuff like
that this definitely wouldn't have
happened without her help
um and with that um thank you again to
all four of you um this has been
wonderful
thank you thank you helen alexander
thank you